I believe that there are latent systems
in the brain and body that have to be
activated in order for us to have a
lucid or mystical moment I've been
chasing the mystical now for at least 20
years and I think people start out in a
in a spiritual quest for a lot of
reasons some people want to be abundant
some people want to be healthy some
people want better relationships and
that's kind of the reason why people
start but as they start creating things
they want in their life and as they
start connecting to this invisible field
of information called the quantum field
all of a sudden you have a very
transcendental moment and your inner
world starts becoming more real than
your outer world and those moments then
leave Lasting Impressions in our brain
because you feel the energy of that
experience and when you feel altered in
some way because you feel more electric
or more alive you pay more attention to
the images in your brain and you're
starting to create memories and now the
brain becomes wired differently and I
think that you perceive a broader
spectrum of reality hey it's EV car
Michael and I make these videos because
I need them because being around
successful entrepreneurs who are pushing
who are driving who are doing amazing
things gives me that extra little
motivational inspirational boost in the
morning every day to help me go off and
accomplish great things too and I hope
that this video gives you that
inspiration as well so today let's learn
how to create anything that you want
enjoy rule number two is change your
beliefs with Bruce Lipton reprogramming
my subconscious mind to do what get rid
of or replace the disempowering programs
with empowering ones and I go here's the
benefit here's the benefit of it once
the new program is in you don't have to
even make any effort why you haven't
made any effort to get where you are
right
now it's your subconscious been doing it
all the time so I said well what if you
put only good stuff in your subconscious
I go well then without any effort you
will have all the good things that you
were looking for health and happiness
and relationships and stuff like that
and that's the
destination because you got to get out
of I'm a victim everyone thinks they're
a victim I go well what does victim mean
powerless and so if I'm I'm telling you
I'm powerless and what do you think is
going to happen and as you went like
that before the answer is this I'll sell
you some power I'll be the
pharmaceutical you want some power I'll
sell you this drug okay I'm this guy
I'll sell you that you'll get more power
more power what did they do they made us
into consumers why I can't do it I'm the
victim but they can get it for me how
much do I pay them I say well hey
religion was based on all this stuff
yeah how how much does it cost me not to
go to hell well 10% of your salary was
tithing I go for what they're going to
protect me from going to hell uh you
know the the spiritual people I go why
am I paying them
10% I can I could create my own Heaven
which I did and all of a sudden it says
stop dis empowering me that is the
message who does it go to it goes to the
medical community that you disempower me
by telling me what my future is going to
be and I buy into the belief in that
first seven years that you control my
health I don't control my health I'd go
to the doctor the and my program is
doctor knows about my health I don't the
doctor says you're going to die in 3
months then guess what you just put in
your brain a pro program of in 3 months
I will be dead and you will I say will
you die of the cancer they said you had
and I go nope you can you die from the
belief of the three months because when
they started doing autopsies on people
that we know they were going to die in
three months of this cancer and they
start finding they didn't die from the
cancer what' they die from the belief
belief controls your life if you believe
you're going to die you can die just
from the belief hi I'm Bruce lion author
of of the bestselling books the biology
belief spontaneous Evolution and the
honeymoon effect I'm here to thank Evan
carmichel for featuring me on his
YouTube channel and I want to let you
know that Evan is giving away links
where you can watch the First episodes
of my special guia series entitled in a
revolution for free Evan is making this
offer to thank you for watching this
video you will find the links in the
description section below thank you rule
number three is understand the three
ring circus with Michael Singer
basically there are three categories or
groups of objects of Consciousness that
you're Consciousness is aware of one is
the outside world if you close your eyes
you don't see the outside world if you
open your eyes ah there it is okay it
comes in I discussed in the book goes
deep tries to be somewhat scientific so
that we fit into an intellectual model
because everything is logical and and
intellectual and reasonable so the fact
of of the matter is most people don't
think about this you don't really see
through your eyes your eyes are sensors
we call them senses but they're sensors
just like computer sensors that are
picking up light turning it into signals
that are being sent up your nervous
system your Optical nervous Optical
nerves and then it is rendering it
inside your mind just like you look at a
flat SC SC EXC me a flat screen TV and
you look at in there that's hard for us
to relate to because we're used our mind
is so intelligent that it creates 3D and
depth perception and everything even
though you're actually back in here
watching what's coming in and I like to
have fun with people I say I'll prove it
to you that it's really just light
that's bouncing off of objects and
coming into your eyes right turn off the
lights and you won't see anything
because then there's no light bouncing
off things that's not how we think we
think it turn off the lights therefore I
can't see no it's because I turned off
the light there's no like bouncing off
the objects and coming reflecting back
into your eyes it's kind of neat isn't
it all right so it's it's fun to talk
about this stuff so one thing of the
three circus is there's an outside world
with all of its objects and there's a
lot of objects out there the second is
that's not all you receive inside not
all you're aware of inside you're also
aware of thoughts which I'm sure we'll
be talking about deeper uh so I just
surface level it you're aware of
thoughts that go on in there are you not
right you you notice thoughts are
talking to you you notice you can make
your thoughts think different things so
you the Consciousness the exact same
Consciousness that is aware of the
outside world is aware of your thoughts
they're not separate not categorizing it
this is the Consciousness that hears my
thoughts that's the Consciousness that
sees the world you can do them both at
the same time you looking at something
and thinking about it and your same
Consciousness is see both and then the
third is your emotions which are quite
different than thoughts and I'm sure
we'll talk more about that but basically
emotion are feelings they're vibrations
that come up they're not thoughts are
thought forms you can actually see a
boat in there you can see you don't see
words but you can hear words they're
talking to you that voice inside your
head emotions are like that they're just
basically shifts in energy patterns
vibrations that you pick up but they're
very strong and they catch your
Consciousness so those are the three
things in the three Circus the outside
world that you're aware of the thoughts
that are inside your head your mind and
the emotions that emanate from your
heart and the Consciousness gets
distracted by those things that's so
it's really funny that the word
distraction becomes a spiritual word
people don't think of it that way but
deep spirituality deals with
distractions that's what it's all about
if you weren't distracted by your
emotions distracted by your thoughts or
distracted by the outside world you
sitting in som the Consciousness would
be able to come back into its source
rule number four is live in fullness
with eart tole the power to
manifest is
in
experiencing
the
fullness of the present moment the
undifferentiated fullness what Jesus
called life in its
fullness in one of the
translations I want you to have life in
its fullness he
said and that is not stuff he not
referring to things life in its fullness
is an inner state of
being it is to experience to know to
realize the beingness within you the I
am which is consciousness itself that is
life that is the fullness of life in the
words of Jesus the fullness of life
is to to to realize
that so that once you realize that and
it is
consciousness you you know yourself as
Consciousness once you know
that
then no future moment can possibly be
better anything that can happen in the
future isn't adding on
to so if you bring
together if you have a vision in your
mind of what it is you want to achieve
or create or
manifest and you bring this Vision into
this sense of
still
fullness that you sense
now and you bring that together that is
the most powerful creative tool the way
that it's usually expressed in Jes Jesus
expressed it too he said when you pray
for
something uh believe that you already
have it that's but I think he probably
used actually slightly different words
but that's how it was written
down he said he probably said feel that
you already have it whatever it is that
you want to have that you think is going
to be you need to you need to feel
already the feeling that you now how do
you do that by feeling that which is
beyond uh the world of phenomena out of
which everything arises which is
consciousness so when you know yourself
as
Consciousness that's already the
Fulfillment rule number five is develop
an abundance mindset with Deepak Chopra
the happiness equation and I think
that's the perfect way to understand the
right mindset for anything including
abundance so here's the happiness
equation H is equal to s plus C plus v
so H stands for
happiness is equal to s s is called set
point in the brain so some people are
seemingly seemingly wired for joy and
opportunity and abundance and some
people are wired seemingly for what do
you call scarcity thinking and also for
looking at
problems this thing called the set point
in the brain determines 50% of your
so-called happiness experience every day
happy people are always looking for
opportunities no matter what so whatever
the situation is instead of saying this
is a problem or an adversity they say
this is an
opportunity automatically they don't
even see the problem they see only the
opportunity the unhappy people only see
the problem always now how does this
happen and it was very interesting to
see the research on this if your parents
and if your social environment in the
first five years of your life um if your
parents particularly and your immediate
social environment your brothers and
sisters if all you heard was criticism
condemning complaining and playing the
victim then your set point is already
always looking for problems so you know
your parents were criticizing condemning
complaining or playing the victim you're
going to always see problems on the
other hand if your parents a were always
joyful number one B they were I call
these the four a they were good
listeners attention appreciation they
notic everyone's gifts around them
including yours as a child appreciation
then affection they showered you with
unconditional love and they accepted you
just as you are not just as they would
like you to be these four is attention
affection appreciation and acceptance
you will grow up to be a happy person
now you say this is bad news because
that means that whether I look at the
world as opportunity or problem is
determined for me already I'm
screw the fact is you are because this
is your condition mine rule number six
is do morning chance with Jack cornfield
every morning after arms round in in the
monastery we would do our morning chants
sometimes before we went out some of
them when we came back and they were
chants of gratitude and prayers may I
use the food that's offered the the
robes that I've been given the care that
I received from others may I use this in
a way that benefits myself and Community
around me and all the beings in this
world may I take these and receive it
with deep
gratitude
gratitude the acknowledgment of the
countless blessings Great and Small that
we receive every single day with every
breath and every
meal gratitude has a trust a confidence
in life itself it feels the same force
that pushes grass through the cracks in
the sidewalk invigorates and keeps you
alive every
day gratitude gladdens the heart it's
not sentimental not jealous not
judgmental it doesn't Envy or
compare gratitude receives in Wonder the
Myriad offerings of the rain and the
earth and the care that supports every
single life rule number seven is change
your Paradigm with Bob Proctor see in
1990 um Joel Barker wrote a book it's
called paradigms he said to be able to
shape your future you have to be willing
and able to change your
Paradigm now I had no idea what a
paradigm was and you might ask yourself
do you really know what a paradigm is do
you understand how the mind works
because the Paradigm has something to do
with the mind I knew nothing about it
but the man
that encouraged me to study this put me
on a track where I just kept going from
one great mentor to another a paradigm
is nothing but a multitude of ideas that
are fixed in the subconscious mind and
so here we are as hard as it is to
believe 20 30 50 60 years later living
exactly the same as we were programmed
when we were little kids do you know
that most people in welfare are fourth
fifth generation welfare recipients it's
rather strange now what do we do well we
leave this situation and we go to school
what does school do well let's look at
it school gave us valuable knowledge
however school never taught us anything
about
paradigms
therefore we frequently do not do what
we already know how to do now think
Superior
knowledge think about
it inferior results what does that do
that causes confusion and frust ation
now think about this for a moment we've
gaed great knowledge but we know nothing
about the Paradigm so watch here here's
the drawing there's the model there's
all the knowledge we got in school we've
got it packed in there but you know
something it doesn't equate to the
results we're getting you're going to
find absolutely brilliant people getting
very bad results you're going to find
people that are brilliant they know
exactly what to do but they don't do it
why it's the paradigm that controls the
behavior and Rule Number Eight the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is rewire your brain for wealth with
John asera when we talk about rewiring
your brain for wealth why do we even use
the word rewire our brain for wealth
like it has to assume that our brain is
wired for wealth right what does that
even mean so when we talk about rewiring
your brain for
wealth it assumes that there is a wiring
already there and the question then
becomes was the wiring there when you
and I were born were we born with any
beliefs were we born with an identity
were we born with a self-image or even a
self-concept were we born with any
attitudes were we born with any habits
were we born with any expectations were
we born with any
Financial set points or
limitations right Financial glass
ceilings and the answer is no there was
there was there were brain cells 100
billion of them or so and over the
course of Our
Lifetime right uh each one of those
brain cells created neural connections
about
10,000 neural connections per cell so if
you want to do some math do 100 B itimes
10,000 huge number and those connections
started to formulate our perspective our
beliefs our Paradigm our attitude our
skills our expectations our set points
right so let's understand the nature of
how our brain became conditioned what
the essence of this wiring is so what
happens is as we you know are born into
this environment with parents with
certain skills certain knowledge um
certain awarenesses um Etc we also have
to assume that
we apply or we we learn the stuff from
them about what's real and what isn't
right we
learned everything from our environment
our parents the meaning we gave things
we learned that if we went to school it
means this if we didn't it means that it
means that this job earns that Etc so we
were born with a complete open slate
right and then we created these neural
patterns and then those neural
patterns went from creation initially to
being what we call is
softwired softwired which means the
neurons that formulated these
connections through effort and awareness
and the meanings we gave things became
softwired not just in the conscious mind
so we could declare the things that we
may believe but through our habits and
our paradigms and our attitude and also
the beliefs that we have about what's
possible you know for us right so when
we're talking about rewiring your brain
for
wealth is it possible that let's say if
you if you make whether it's $11,000 a
month or $1,000 a day it does doesn't
matter that the more you've been earning
that amount of money that becomes your
financial or wealth set point the more
we reinforce a pattern does it not mean
that the pattern then reinforces itself
through
automaticity which is one of the brains
ways to conserve energy right there's
neuroplasticity our brain's ability to
make connections there's neurogenesis
which is our brain's ability to create
new neurons which we once thought wasn't
happening but it does but then
automaticity is once those neuron
patterns are
formulated they run automatically it's
part of something called your default
mode
network if you think money is scarce you
hoard it because you believe that no
more money will come to you if you know
money is abundant more money will flow
to you this isn't about being wasteful
does it doesn't mean you have to go and
always empty your pockets and buy a lot
of dumb stuff and throw away all your
other stuff it doesn't mean you have to
waste your
money but it's switching the mindset of
money is not just some scarce thing that
you don't know how to make that you will
never have more of and so you need to
hoard every single dollar that you've
got this is honestly something that I am
continuing to rewire myself on I
struggled a lot with money especially in
the early days of my business um even
growing up I I grew up in a middle class
family my parents spent my parents are
behind me on the wall hold on there we
go this is me when I'm eight or nine and
my parents here they believed in
education a lot and they didn't have a
ton of money we weren't poor but they
spent all of their money basically on
putting the three of us kids I have two
sisters through private school so any
money that they made basically poured
into our education and as a result we
didn't have you know money for other
things and um where my friends at these
fancy schools were getting you know BMWs
for their 16th birthday so they can go
off and drive uh you know I didn't get
any of that and it's not whato was me
but it's more I just had a scarce
mentality around money in my first
business I was making 300 bucks a month
I was eating the same bean salad lunch
every day because it would fill me up
and wasn't uh very expensive when we
celebrated a win we'd go to McDonald's
if we got a new client like hey we sold
another piece of our software we go to
McDonald's and order a large fries and
share that between the three of us cuz
it was cheap and we wanted just some
little way to celebrate
and I just remember how painful it was
to feel like you have no money and you
can't buy stuff and I couldn't hang out
with my friends and I couldn't do what I
wanted to do
and I think that has a traumatic effect
you know I mean maybe that's you as well
you you have a scarcity mindset around
money that you don't know how to make it
and so anything you've got you got to
really hold on to it and protect it and
again I'm not advocating for being
Reckless or stupid or just throwing
money away be be smart about how you're
going to invest and use your money the
more important thing is developing the
mindset that you can create money that
by bringing a a lot of value to people
you can make more money you can turn it
into something so one of the things that
I've done recently that that um has
helped both myself and Nina my wife is
we create what we call a care fund and
every month when we're doing our numbers
uh Nina will put together how much we've
made this month how much cashs come in
ETC and then we allocate a certain
percentage for a care fund that we have
to go off and
spend uh either for ourselves or for
other people and so my default is to
invest invest invest invest invest right
like invest back into the business
invest into into into markets invest in
assets just invest invest invest invest
invest
invest the and that's a that's a great
good mindset the downside of that is you
don't get to see the impact that it can
create and so said you know what we need
to dedicate a percentage every month to
go and help somebody else and maybe it's
help ourselves you um on the weekend nah
bought a uh very expensive
purse we went shopping she bought a very
expensive purse we bought a Chanel bag
and probably more expensive than she's
ever bought a bag and for me it's like
oh my gosh you can't be spending this
amount of money on a
bag but it's worth celebrating yourself
so you know what like we earned that we
did so much work in our business you can
you can go and afford that we've also
used the money to donate the Charities
we've also used the money to uh support
our family and things that they needed
or wanted in their lives and it's
something that we have to spend every
month Nina ask hey can we just save it
so we can invest more and then that
leads to more in the future like no
we're already saving other money to do
that like that has to be spent every
month and so where we have to sit this
might sound crazy we have to sit down
every month and figure out how are we
going to spend this money because my
default is not to go and spend the
default is to invest or just to save and
so doing that it doesn't have to be a
big amount of money it could it could be
a hundred bucks a month that you force
yourself to spend on making somebody
else's life better or even your own like
that thing that you would never buy for
yourself you know what I've worked hard
like I'm going to buy it or you're going
to go buy somebody a meal or you're
going to go and give a home first than
$100 right like you're going to you're
going to do something with
it because what it does it starts to
change your mentality around it it
starts to make you feel
like more will come that I'm
creating and so whether it's 10 bucks a
100 bucks 1,000 bucks 10,000 bucks like
you know whatever it is I'm not
advocating you go drain your bank
account and just go crazy and buy a
Chanel bag you know but allocating a
certain percentage every month
so that you can start to rewire your
beliefs around money that it's not just
super scarce so that would be step
number one right allocate some kind of
budget to helping especially others cuz
when you can when you help others it
just makes you feel so good and you can
help others in a lot of ways you can
help them with your time you can help
them with your expertise you can help
them you know not just give a man a fish
but teach them how to fish right but
there's there's the immediate
gratification of helping somebody buying
the coffee for the person on line or
seeing somebody that you know that that
25 bucks 100 bucks will make a big
difference and like you were able to
afford to do
that gives you the extra oomph to go off
and want to do more of it like if you
know that that 25 bucks change that
person's life imagine if you can give
them 2500 bucks but to do that you'd
have to go off and build a bigger
business right so the the core of your
business needs to be serving and helping
and contributing back and you can't
afford yet to give somebody 2500 bucks
which you could if you kept building
your business and so just gives that
little extra bit of motivation and
incentive right to get out there and
start to do it to allocate a certain
percentage second is to be around people
who are who are generous be around the
people who have the mindset that you
want to have if there's a belief that
you want to adopt the fastest way to do
it is to be around the people who
constantly are screaming that belief the
people who are constantly living that
belief so if you love my view on
something great hanging around me more
often there's lots of videos you love
Grant cardone's view or Gary B's view or
Oprah's view on something the more you
hang around them and watch their content
and read their books and listen to their
speeches the more you're going to start
to adopt that same belief
system so if you want to believe that
money is not scarce then you need to be
hanging around people who believe that
money is not scarce because probably the
people in your life believe money is
really scarce and the people that I grew
up with believe that money is really
scarce the closest people around me and
so it doesn't mean you stop hanging out
with them but you need to inject new
people in even if it's just through
YouTube videos of the people who believe
the thing that you want to believe
because otherwise you get pulled back
down because your environment has been
created to keep you where you are so if
you want to change where you are you
have to change the environment and it
used to be that you had to you have to
really change you had to go somewhere
else you had to move out you had to find
a mentor to hang out with and have
coffee with consistently now you can do
it through through YouTube I've been
inspired by tons of mentors who I've
never
met because of the content that I've
learned from them on YouTube but it
takes the effort and intention to be
consistently around it that this is the
belief system that you want to have you
need to create that habit for yourself
from the things that are on the wall to
the clothes that you wear to the the
media that you're consuming every day
being intentional with that to say this
is this this is the belief system that I
want to have I recognize I'm not there
yet but this is this belief system I
want to have and I want to be around the
people who believe this to their core
because their belief in that thing is
stronger than your belief against it and
whoever is more confident wins and so
when you're around the people who
believe that thing so much they will
pull you towards them to start having
that similar belief system and then
everything starts to change I think
having a scarcity mindset is extremely
limiting I've I've lived through really
intense versions of it I still feel like
I'm coming out of it I've grown a lot
compared to where I used to be but still
have a lot a long ways to go I probably
still have
things that I'm holding on to that I
shouldn't uh I probably still should be
more generous than I am um and I'm I'm
working through it as well I might just
be a little bit further ahead on the
curve definitely compared to 19-year-old
Evan who thought money was the most most
scarce thing in the world when you can
learn to make that rewiring happen
that's how you start to change your life
so if you look at the people around you
look at their beliefs especially around
money and see what do they think and
then see where they're at in their life
compared to the people who have
different beliefs around money and where
they're at who would you rather be and
you could be there you could be that
person if you start to change your
beliefs your environment start to help
more people with it start to allow the
money to flow because when you start to
believe that you can create a lot more
money for yourself a lot of things start
to change I know you all have big goals
Big Dreams big aspirations just like I
do you've got Ambitions to become an
amazing person to build your career to
create to contribute to give to be an
awesome human being but all of that is
impossible without great habits set up
if you don't have routine and structure
set up in a way that will keep keep you
on track then you you'll fall off and
and and having new goals without new
habits is kind of like you know having a
new car without wheels you know the
habits are the wheels they're the things
that make you able to achieve the goals
so you got to have good habits but the
challenge for most people isn't that
knowledge I mean you know you need to
have good habits it's you can't keep the
Habit going right have you ever started
at the new year you're going to get
healthier and you start that habit of
working out more on a more regular basis
and then it goes away or you say you
know I'm going to be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my L and you start being nice for 2 or 3
days and then on the fourth day you're a
jerk you know and you're like what what
happened I said I was going to be nicer
it's that you didn't set up the most
important thing you needed to maintain a
habit so what's the biggest secret I've
learned in almost 20 years in this field
it's so simple but most people don't
have it it's called trigger moments you
have to set up trigger moments to
activate your habits what do I mean by
that well let's say you want to become
uh a better person you know you want to
become more kind more patient more
loving with people now you can just set
that intention or write that down in
your vision your journal or set up on a
vision board that you look at once in a
while but in daytoday life it's not
enough you need things to trigger you to
remind you to be that particular kind of
person right it's almost like if you
could have a little angel speaking in
your ear all day long to tell you what
to do and how to be you'd obviously
become better well that makes sense well
let's use that idea let's use that idea
by setting up alarms on our phones that
trigger us to do the very things we need
to do this is going to be so basic
you're going to laugh and then I'll also
tell you how I've literally taught this
to Fortune 50 CEOs and they said it was
the one thing that changed their life
the most dramatically so let's start
with with this let's I have a goal in
mind let's say you want to become more
present and calm throughout the day
again you could write that down on a
journal I'm going to be more present and
calm you could meditate in the morning
say today I'm going to be more present
and calm and you you could you can start
out with good intentions but those fall
apart without a trigger moment set up
throughout the day to remind you that so
what if you did this what if you just
set up on your phone three alarms during
the day with a label that said close
your
eyes take 10 deep breaths in remind
yourself to be calm so let's say you're
going through your day it's crazy right
it's 10:00 a.m. and all a sudden Bing
your phone goes off you look down and it
says close your eyes take 10 deep
breaths and then again it happens at
2:00 and again it happens at 6:00 p.m.
and again it happens at 8:00 p.m. what's
going to happen you always look at your
phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this world
worldwide we're talking about hundreds
of thousands of people I've Ted to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that that changed
everything and you'll think once you set
it up that the next day you you'll
you'll forget about it no that alarm
will go off you forgot you set the dang
alarm there it goes off in your face and
you're like all right I'm trying to be
calmer and more present close my eyes
take 10 deep breaths reground myself
here we go you can't do it once a day
you have to have moments throughout the
day that trigger you to enact the new
Behavior I know this makes sense to you
but it's a challenge for a lot of people
because they never set those things up
so what if you did it with an alarm so
for example for me on the opposite
Spectrum I don't want to just be calmer
and more present I Want More Energy
throughout the day so here's what I do
one of my big trigger moments is every
time my butt hits a chair I don't care
if I'm on a plane or I was like where
we're shooting here I I wrote a lot of
my books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to right my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes now at 50
minutes the timer goes it starts buzzing
and I look at that and I go oh that's my
trigger to get energy so I stand up I go
get some water I take a glass of water
drink it down I do some stretches and I
do some exercise just really briefly or
I'll go for a walk whatever it is but
I'll do something that usually takes
just 2 to 5 minutes then I'll sit back
down I'll set that 50-minute alarm and
I'll work and what that does is every 50
minutes it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that 2 3 4:00 time where I'm like ah you
know why because I've triggered my day
so that my energy is maintained
throughout the day makes sense right
this could be as simple as let's say you
want to be healthier in your life okay
let's set up some trigger moments for
you in this way let's say every time you
drop off the kids on the way back to the
house you stop at the grocery store and
get some fresh produce that's just a
trigger it's like okay did one thing Dro
kids off now tied to that triggered from
that action drop kids off is go to
health food store or let's say you want
to get healthier in the morning one of
the easiest ways to help people maintain
a better exercise program is this set a
trigger you wake up in the morning your
first action is to drink water put your
exercise shoes on uh might get dressed
if you were naked just saying so you get
dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
door frame triggers what do you mean by
that when you walk walk into a new room
to have a psychological trigger go off
in your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
if I've been working all day and I'm
going to walk in I'm going to see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said the three words
said the three words and I did this so
many times that now when I walk through
a door my mind automatically triggers
those three words and I remember to be
those three words so what words would
you love to have describe you as a
person that you would be happy if that
was how people described you what would
those words be have those and now set
them up in your life I teach Executives
to do this as well I have them have a
doorframe trigger when they walk into
their office in the morning as soon as
they walk through that door frame they
have boom three words go through the
their mind about how they want to be
perceived as a leader I have them set up
another door every time they walk into a
meeting into the conference room when
they walk through the doors of the
conference room they have another three
words that trigger off for them and it
just reminds them how to be so these
aren't big crazy things a lot of people
they think they have to completely
change their life what would change your
life completely is setting up more
trigger moments and associations that
when you see something you do this that
when this action is taken then that
happens that when you uh have the
opportunity to set up alarms on your
phone you set them up so that you're
interrupted in your everyday life to
remind yourself to stick to the habits
to stick to the intention you do that
enough on a continual basis you'll find
yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that every Everything
Changes I had been raised to believe
that if you're going to earn a lot of
money you've got to be really smart I
knew I wasn't that smart but I was
earning a lot of money so I knew that
wasn't right
um I was raised to believe if you don't
go to school you'll never get a good job
I didn't have a good job I owned the
whole
company I couldn't figure it out do you
know it took me N9 and a half
years well n and a half years later I
met this man that I showed you his name
Leeland Val vandell he um he changed my
life completely he introduced me to a
concept I'm going to introduce you to
and when he did that it was like
everything I'd been studying I'd been
studying a lot of information but I had
studied this book I'd give this book to
people and they didn't change and what
he did he brought everything together
for me in a relatively short period of
time now here's a couple of things he
told me if you'll go back screen scunt
and he said Bob he he he pointed out he
said said you are a unique individual
and he said so am I so is everybody else
and he said you can literally create
your own economy you can do that and he
said the only thing standing between you
and what you want is yourself he's all
about the Mind Bob he said it's about
your marvelous mind then he started
thanks God then he started to talk to me
about the mind and he said you know it's
a strange thing Bob when we get talking
about the mind nobody's ever seen the
mind they have never seen the mind now
keep in mind that I was a very
uneducated person um when you talk about
the mind I mean I would think of
psychiatrist psychologists behavioral
scientists now he said you want to get
rid of those ideas he said the way I'm
going to explain it to you is the way it
was explained to me and he said um we
can change we can show children how the
mind
functions and he said I'm going to show
you something here that's rather
interesting and he said Bob
understanding the mind and uh and
working in harmony with the laws
governing the mind is essential if you
really want to win in life and then he
started to tell me what a paradigm was
and he said a paradigm is a mental
program that has almost exclusive
control over our habitual behavior and
he started talk about that he said it's
a program in your subconscious mind that
controls your behavior and the Paradigm
has almost exclusive control over our
habitual behavior and almost all of our
behavior is
Habitual now I said I want you to think
about this and I want you to think about
it we get out of bed in the morning and
uh we bang away we go we move into a
routine and if you're living with
someone else you don't mess around with
their routine because you just don't do
that we've all got a routine and we go
into a routine and we do that day after
day and most people do it for their
whole life ear nil used used to say most
people tiptoe through life hoping they
make it safely to death it's rather an
interesting concept and the Paradigm is
the program in your subconscious mind
now he said here's the crazy part about
it Bob the people that write this
program the ones that wrote the code for
the program um they really didn't know
what they were doing think of this for a
moment I've got a computer here it's in
a phone I've got another computer right
in front of me and then here I've got um
I've got a pad and um these are
computers now there's people write
programs for these computers they write
code and they really know what they're
doing and they're very very good and the
program for me to put the slides up here
that's a program it's a PowerPoint
program and um the things work like like
a charm well the people that are writing
the code for for them are very well
educated and really understand what
they're doing but he said the people
that are writing the program for the
code that runs your life they didn't
know what they were doing now most
people don't even know that they have a
program think of this for a moment how
do you account for a person going to the
very best schools in the world getting
prestigious degrees then spend the rest
of their life losing how do you account
for that how do you account for the fact
that a person will come up with degrees
that'll run right off the end of a
business card and maybe not able to get
a half decent
job very insecure how do you account for
that well I'm going to tell you how
there's a part of your mind that gathers
information there's a part of your mind
when you read the book you store the
information in that part of your mind
but that part of your mind is not the
part that controls the behavior of this
thing you're living in your body is an
instrument of your mind it is an
instrument of your mind and it's your
body then moves into action and produces
the results you're getting just give
yourself
permission to want the things that you
want and unless you believe that you're
worthy unless that you practice love
you're never going to think that you
deserve the things that you want right
so tell the
story okay so I'm probably G to stop
hysterically I'll shorten it I'll
shorten it so the the bottom line is is
that so in
1990 I was a senior in college at
Dartmouth and my parents came to visit
from Western Michigan and we went to
this place called Simon Pierce which is
a famous glass blowing Mill and as we
walked into the restaurant I had an
experience that you may be able to
relate to and that is I walked in and I
immediately saw this painting hanging on
the wall and it was about the size of a
door only horizontal and it was a
Vermont landscape and I was drawn into
it immediately like I was no long longer
in that restaurant I was standing in
that field I could feel that breeze I'd
never ever had an experience like that
with a painting you ever had experience
like that with art no I mean not like
that not like that I mean my yeah my
sense was that this is very atypical for
you very so
I kind of lost it the the the the
restaurant was quiet and then I leaned
back I'm suddenly kind of back in the
moment I'm like I'm going to own this
painting someday it just that was what
was right there and I looked at the
price and it said like $3,000 I'm like
not today and I went back and I sat down
and that was it but the painting never
left my mind you see there's something
called the zigen AR effect I I always
say it wrong but it's like there's a
checklist in your brain that when you
have a moment where you're like this is
important your brain puts it on a
checklist like a notch yes a notch
happens and now your brain as part of
the filter in the brain is always going
going to be kind of scanning the
subconscious to let anything into your
mind related to that incident it can be
positive by the way like with the
painting or this is how trauma happens
too like you have this high-intensity
emotional experience that notches
something in your brain and now your
brain kicks in to remember so uh bottom
line is uh I always thought about that
painting years go by whenever somebody
would say Vermont I'd think of the
painting I don't know why I can't
explain it never wanted a painting
before was not an art student it's going
to lawo like you're out collecting art
no no no and so I you know fast forward
the story 10 years and my uh H Chris and
I are are engaged and we're going to go
up to Vermont to see the leaves and
immediately I'm like we got to go to
Simon Pierce I got to show you the
painting so we pull up to the mill and
we walk in and right in front there is
Boom a painting by the same artist Gail
Shepard and I'm like oh my God it's here
and we race all around the place and
it's gone and the funny thing was and
this is the way your brain works Chris
was more disappointed than I was I
literally turned to him and said it's
okay dude like it'd be weird if we're
still here after 10 years I'm going to
track this thing down I actually said to
him you know what's going to happen
Chris I'm going to be able to buy this
like 40 years from now it's going to be
hanging in the corporate Lobby of some
building and I'm going to have to track
down the owner and pay like quadruple
the money they pay but I'm going to own
this yes so a couple years pass and um
it's my birthday I think I was turning
30 and Chris says uh Chris gets a couple
people
to give money and he said I could buy
anything I wanted with it so I had I had
what 500 bucks now I'm pregnant at the
time with our first kid I should have
bought a crib or stools but for whatever
reason the zigen archa takes over and
I'm like the painting so I call the mill
and I get this guy on the phone I'm like
uh you know I want to buy a kale
Shephard piece
and I said could you send me Polaroids
and he's like sure and I tell him the
budget and he goes I I'll send you
Polaroids of some of her smaller things
M and she's like blowing up in the
meantime right yeah she's a very very
successful Vermont landscape artist and
so
I I I I say to him you know by the way
there's this one painting and I describe
the painting I had seen over 10 years
ago and he said 'w that was way before
my time but I bet Gail will know
and I'm like Gail you know Gail he's
like of course I know Gail she like
lives in in down the road here's her
number so for two days I paced around
the apartment with 500 bucks in my
pocket driving Chris crazy because I
felt like what am I going to say to her
and I must be a weirdo I've been
stalking this lady I've been thinking
about her for 10 years I can't afford a
painting you know what who am I to buy a
painting like what the hell so finally
Chris is like would you call her or I'm
going to call her you're driving me
crazy so I call her and I start talking
a mile a minute and she was
amazing and then um I said by the way
there is this one painting and I go and
I explain this painting there's a stand
of popler trees down the center and a
big mountain scape behind it and this
beautiful blue Vermont sky and geese
flying in formation overhead and I could
hear her thinking on the other end of
the line and she said you know Mel I've
done so many large
scale uh paintings over the years I'd
hate to mistake the one you're talking
about but I'll tell you what what if my
husband and I meet you and Chris at the
Mill at Simon Pierce and we'll walk all
around and have lunch and I'll tell you
the stories behind every painting and if
you don't see what you like there I'll
take you back to my studio which is a
couple miles down the river and you can
look at everything I'm working on and if
you don't see anything you like there
then you can go through all my slides
and see if you can find that painting
that you saw 10 years ago and I said
deal so a month passes we go up to the
mill I walk in we meet each other she's
amazing she's like twice our age just
incredibly cool lady she's walking
around as we're walking around looking
at these paintings Rich I've got I'm
like eight months pregnant I'm realizing
these are 10 times the amount of money
that I
have I can't afford this like I don't I
don't have this kind of
money and I'm getting like more and more
into that impostor syndrome what am I
doing mode oh my God I'm so embarrassed
I'm meeting somebody I idolize I don't
deserve to be here right wasting her
time cuz she thinks she's going to get a
Payday out of this correct we sit down
and she goes now that you're sitting
down I have something to tell
you
um she said there's only been two times
in my career as an artist that I've done
two studies of the same
peace and your painting is one of them
it's one of a
pair she knew all along she knew all
along she was playing games with you
about not knowing which painting yeah
and she said the sister peace to the one
that you saw all those years ago is
sitting in my studio right now where
it's been for the past 11
years I start sobbing everybody's like
totally emotional her husband's like you
should have seen her when you she was on
the phone with you it was like she saw a
ghost so we get in the car and we drive
to the mill and when we walk in there in
the center of this massive kind of Barn
Studio space is an easel with a painting
taped up with painters tape on it and it
was the sister to my painting there were
slight differences not as much movement
in the grass but it
was one of the most extraordinary
experiences of my life it was as if time
suspended and I was standing before that
painting in
1990 saying it would be mine and there I
was 11 years
later standing in front of it and then I
realized oh my God I can't
afford this and Chris walks over and
he's like what's wrong and I'm like just
promise me someday like promise me that
I don't need a a jewelry I don't need a
car like just promise me you will buy me
this thing and he kind of leans over and
goes hey Gail how much for the big one
and she said um Mel can have it for 500
bucks cuz clearly when I was making it
11 years ago I was making it for
her
yeah and so it hangs in my kitchen it's
on the back of the book um this is the
galley though right so wait is it in the
is it I think so yeah yeah and um it's a
reminder every day that your mind is
designed to help you get what you want I
never stop believing that I could make
it happen and when you tell your mind
what's important to you there is
extraordinary
science that proves that your mind has a
live and everchanging filter a live
Network that changes how it views the
world What it lets in what it blocks out
and if you program your mind correctly
and if you're clear about what you want
to create your mind will help you get
what you want our affirmations a total
waste of time what about declarations
you know declaring that something is
real that it is what about I promise and
you don't really believe the promise so
let's understand something first and
foremost and you know who this is it's
John think about affirmations like my
good friend Dr John D Martini does and
in my discussions with him he's got one
of the best um ideas around that I like
it's an affirmation is really all about
affirming something in one's mind so an
affirmation isn't about stating
something that you don't believe as a
truth no it's taking something that you
may not believe and affirming it in your
mind so that you start to believe it and
you start to behave in ways in alignment
with what it is that you believe so
think about this were you born with any
beliefs
no so other people's beliefs in most
cases were given to you right me too
through parents teachers siblings uh TV
things we read things we we watched Etc
and so when I started using affirmations
back when I was 19
it started off with things like I'm so
happy and grateful for the fact that I
am now achieving all my goals and dreams
now at the time I wasn't when I would
say
that I would hear this little voice in
my head going bull that's not true but I
was also taught to understand that that
voice was that critical voice that we
all have almost like a a little you know
critical person you know sitting on your
shoulder you know trying to remind you
that you're not good enough not worthy
enough not smart enough Etc and I was
taught to say next just take that idea
and go next and then go I'm so happy and
grateful for the fact that I am
achieving all my goals and dreams the
repetition side of affirmations with
emotion activates
okay electrical signals in your brain
right when the electrical signals in
your brains are firing they call them
neurons that fire together the
affirmation wire together now why is
that important well if I don't believe
something like I'm so happy and grateful
for the fact that I'm achieving every
one of my goals and dreams and yet I
repeat it I emotionalize it I feel it
and I say yes this is what I want to
believe this what I'm choosing to
believe I'm deliberately and
consciously creating my belief system
well why not do that deliberately
instead of believing all the that's out
there right that people believe because
of their experiences so what happens is
if we fire these neurons enough in our
brain and we wire them enough in our
brain they go from conscious effort I
don't believe it to well maybe I do
believe it to I believe it to how do I
behave in ways that I believe
that's how we develop our beliefs that's
how we develop our identity that's how
we develop our character I think we've
all experienced those synchronicities
where you're thinking about something or
you have an intention and all of a
sudden you start to see reality kind of
conform itself around you in some way
and you're not going anywhere to get it
uh somehow it seems to be coming to you
and there's a very direct correlation
between energy and reality so when you
start to synchronize your energy to a
possibility that exists in the quantum
field and you have a coherent brain
there's a very very specific signal that
we can send out that's very very
coherent and
clear and when we match that brain
coherence with heart coherence it is the
heart that acts as a magnet and draws
the experience back to us
so the thought being electrical charge
and the feeling being the magnetic
charge and how you think and how you
feel broadcasts information into the
quantum field and I think whatever we
broadcast into the field is our
experiment with
Destiny so we either create from the
field or we create from matter and if we
create from matter as bodies local in
space and time and three-dimensional
reality we have to move through space to
get what we want we have to move back
and forth to work and drive there uh to
manifest our dreams and in creating in
threedimensional reality takes time and
it takes
energy sometimes uh people get so lost
in reality they forget what their dreams
were because there's too much time
between cause the thought and effect the
experience and that's what separation
does in three-dimensional reality
creating from the field and getting
Beyond yourself your Association to
everything physical and known and being
able to enter
through a small door the eye of the
needle the quantum field passing through
that eye of the needle as pure
Consciousness and connecting to a field
and teaching people how to create from
the field instead of from matter
connected to that unified field uh to
Source energy when they create from
source and they're Connected To Source
and source is the cause that creates
matter the effect if we create from
Source connected to it from the field
instead of from matter we don't have to
go anywhere now to get what we want we
begin to draw the experiences to us so
by
combining heart coherence with brain
coherence now we have a Wi-Fi signal and
all we have to do is synchronize our
energy to some intention with some
emotion and tune in to the energy of the
future and the longer you're conscious
of this energy the more you draw your
future to you and if you keep practicing
it every day it's going to become
familiar to you and all of a sudden that
will be your natural energy and when you
change your energy you change your life
and the more coherent the signatures
electromagnetically the more refined The
Experience uh we have when you think a
deliberate thought of what you
want um then Law of Attraction will
employ the universe and all people
circumstances and events to move you to
what you've asked for and to move what
you've asked for to you and so if if if
you think about that there is just
action would be really really hard for
you to reach all of the people
circumstances and events manipulate all
of them to receive what you want and if
you really reflect well on your life and
things that have happened in your life
you kind of
see that actually that happened for me
all I did was moved to here or all I did
was moveed to there and I received what
I wanted thought creates all of the
appearances in the world and thought
creates everything in your life so it's
pretty darn powerful right and what you
think about is what you get what you
focus on is what will manifest in your
life and everyone is
manifesting their day every single day
we're doing it um we are not aware of
course necessarily of thoughts but
thoughts come we energize them and then
they will manifest unless we cancel that
thought out um with another thought with
a thought that contradicts it but I
remember Lester levenson would say every
single thought
manifests and I just thought that was
incredible I had known the secret for
years and years and years and Lester
levenson was a real master um and he
said every single thought manifests and
I was just wow that's how powerful they
are
so so thoughts are your superpower to be
do and
have what you want to experience and
have and do in your life and and so if
you ask um an athlete or if you talk to
a coach a really brilliant coach right
of a sports team then you will find that
visualization and these principles that
I'm talking about are a big part of
their training that they have to be they
have to see themselves winning the game
they have to see themselves winning the
match there is is a really incredible
tennis player that's a very big
fan um a champion tennis player that's a
really big fan of the sacret who uses a
secret this is what he does he sees that
he has won the match before he walks out
onto that court and and it's the same
for um for teams it's the same for
athletes in the Olympic Games running a
race and seeing that they've won yes
they run the race but what has them win
the race is that
they saw themselves winning before they
even got on the starting block and they
saw it and believed it and felt it and
so they just everything lined up for
them in the perfect way they drew the
perfect Lane everybody else was was
moved in exactly the right position and
they got a really great start and they
won the race and so thought is just so
so powerful so athletes but also do you
know the astronauts in the Apollo um
program did
visualization before they went to the
moon and they visualized Landing back on
Earth safely and so that's how important
V visualiz visualization is just thought
in pictures by the way it's it's it's
still thought it's just the same thing
okay it's just thought in pictures so if
you took a person who had zero
resistance and you lock them in a room
no if you took a person that had zero
resistance that person thought about
what they wanted zero resistance lock
them in a room what they wanted will
come to them the universe will move
people circumstances and events and
bring that right to them it must it
absolutely must because if you have no
resistance you have Unleashed a law that
just cannot be stopped and so you will
manifest it will come to
you because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hash tag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want to unlock the Law of
Attraction check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there 90% of those thoughts are the same
thoughts as the day before so what is
the likelihood of something happening
different in your life if 90% of those
thoughts